Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie
So, long overdue channel update
for all the awesome stuff that's gonna be happening this winter
So think of this as an Emergency Awesome Trailer.
If you've only been watching for a little while,
or you're not sure what's going on, you have to imagine
what would it look like, if Deadpool had his own YouTube channel
One, he would probably make fun of everybody and
probably be a lot of stabbing.
And, since YouTube frowns on stabbing,
most of my time is spent just trying to make
funny Easter egg videos or explanations of big comic book arcs
or science-fiction genre.
Like, I'm a big Game of Thrones fan, very fantasy.
So, the big thing that is happening right now is that
most of television is coming back.
So, you have Flash, you have Ghost Rider,
the other DC TV shows.
So, usually what I'll do is I'll post videos
for episodes the night that they air, unless I think
it's absolute hot garbage.
There aren't that many shows that I still watch
that I think are hot garbage
This is meant to be fun, so I just
try to make it as fun as possible.
That's like one of the 7 deadly sins on my YouTube channel.
Being a bummer is punishable by beheading.
So while, a lot of television is coming back in the next
couple weeks. Like Flash, Arrow, Supergirl
Legends of Tomorrow. Marvel's television stuff
is kind of already up and going.
But most of the movies like DC and Marvel
Like Spider-Man Homecoming, Thor: Ragnarok,
Justice League.
are in the process of shutting down
over the next couple of months
So, the types of videos that I make for movies
and for TV Shows just change depending on
what time of year it is
and what you guys wanna talk about.
So, if you're new to the channel
and you're not sure what kind of videos I make
or what I'm going to be doing week-to-week
as we work into the fall, you can look at my videos page
and just scan down briefly
and it'll give you a pretty good idea for what's going on
you know, trailer videos, easter egg videos
funny mashup videos like Thor's hammer
or an explanation of some big real life WTF twist
like when Marvel Studios kind of split in two
and went off by itself to start making its films without
oversight. Or like the big Sony announcement
when they announced that Spider Man was joining
the Marvel Universe
So if there are any videos that you guys
don't see me making that you really want me to do
just let me know in the comments
But, generally it's gonna be a really fun winter
there's so much awesome stuff that's coming back
So, if you are just finding me for the first time,
Be sure to Subscribe to get everything
I do giveaways week-to-week for Marvel, DC,
Game of Thrones, The Walking Dead stuff
So, the best way to find out what videos I'm working on
day-to-day. If you're not sure, like what I'm gonna be
posting later in the day
is Twitter, Facebook. I usually post updates on what
I'm working on
YouTube is in the process of rolling out
some new features that will make it
a little bit to find out what the hell is going on
day-to-day.
But I don't think that is going to be a thing for at least
another couple of months
Any time YouTube rolls out some new cool feature
it always takes months for it to roll out.
So like you may have seen the new end cards
There's like new end cards that you can click on
if you're on your mobile phone
But it's not on every operating system
It doesn't work in every browser right now
All that stuff is included in the description
But if you have any questions about the stuff that I'm
gonna be doing this winter, just let me know in the comments
But, Comic Book TV Shows, movies
genre stuff like Game of Thrones, walking dead
pretty safe bet that I'll be making videos about everything
the only time I won't make a video about something is if
it is really boring
or there's like something else that is way
more interesting
You may notice that I try to alternate between
Marvel and DC videos
and other stuff too
So, the only exception to that
is if Marvel or DC that it wants
to give us a heart attack
and just drop a lot of trailers or
something crazy
all in the same day for a bunch of different stuff
that's probably the only time you'll see like
a bunch of DC videos
without seeing any Marvel videos
or vice versa, like with a bunch of Marvel
and no DC
But generally, I try to keep it pretty
even
so its gonna be a really awesome winter.
There's more comic book stuff happening now
then ever before, so I try
to stay on top of everything
but if there's something you think I'm missing
or I haven't made a video about something
feel free to SPAM the comments
So I'll say new round of the giveaway starts now
It's a $20 Amazon gift card
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
If you're not sure how giveaways work,
all you have to do to enter a giveaway
be a subscriber and leave a comment
giveaways are only open to people who subscribe
they are international, so if you don't live in the United States
you can still participate in giveaways
I just try to make them as easy and painless as possible
winners are usually given a shoutout
in the next video
so, I'll start a Flash giveaway when I post my Flash video on Tuesday
the winner will be announced when I post my next DC video after that
it's the same thing for Marvel giveaways too.
So I announce a Marvel giveaway
the winner gets announced in the next Marvel video
so get hyped, there's so much crazy stuff happening for the rest of the year.
While you guys wait for that to post you can click here
for that Spiderman homecoming Iron man easter egg
and you can click here to get ready for the flash Season 3
Thank you so much for watching let's high five and I'll see you guys tonight